[Music]
you Unstoppable D take the shot I miss
so
badly are we done I miss my horses
mid-range dagger no look
Hammer all those three M chinups let me
to this you're tired now you can
[Applause]
rest game to Miami is a sure thing we've
got all the leverage right Le's got nine
ranks for a reason this is the story of
how we followed up in disappointing
finals he
he you wanted to see me Godfather yes
Jimmy with an even worse off
seon we need another hero another Alpha
but boss I'm the alpha we'll just work
harder this year that's heat culture I'm
right I am heat culture this is a tale
of
huus
greed and
[Music]
tragedy here's his coordinates get him
why doesn't he come here the city won't
let him leave this is how the heat
flamed out in Portland what kind of
hippie [__] is this Jimmy all you
got to try our coffee have you met scoop
H damn Dame you do need help
put your
[Music]
hands
[Applause]
[Music]
now thanks wow Portland how do I begin
to fix this I'm so close to being heated
but this is a business I got to screw
away I'm sorry for theor that sorry
first round I forgive you calm down you
also get Tyler hero damn son I guess
ain't no friends in this business it is
what it is feel me you're not
idiots whatever happened to loyalty you
have wound
here don't go Dame time I'm the dog here
I'll get us
out around you isn't that what you
wanted don't expect me to stand in the
corner away from my
shot I just bought your jersey I need my
dog after you I moved
here now we want to hold on to even
more I can run all day but I think it's
time to blow up another small
Market
but that's way too intense no that's
just
Jimmy why is this so difficult hey
someone left all these bombs around
sorry I'm late I had to f off the
Raptors yianis no no no I can't let you
go with him you think you can come in
here all cocky for No sacrifice and
threaten to blow us up the roxs rested
us a we package they never demanded
anything from us so take him yanis he's
yours oh wow the Cream City Dojo is now
stack maybe I will stay sorry Jimmy but
now we both know we're ready for a
partner
thanks we got
[Applause]
play I mean Pat Riley's only got nine
Rings guys got to go
I'm so close to
being sh
[Music]
slaps